welcome back to omics logic where we
simplify bioinformatics and help make
onyx data analysis logical
in this short video we will discuss
genomics what is genomic data
how is it organized analyzed and
interpreted to be such a powerful
resource in the hands of clinicians
researchers and entrepreneurs that are
reading the dna code to battle cancer
fight off infectious diseases and even
solve crimes
let's start by reviewing some of the
fundamentals of genomics just like the
book
the dna code is organized letters
form sentences sentences form paragraphs
paragraphs are organized into chapters
knowing how to read this code can help
us decipher the full story about who we
are
and look into our history understanding
how we are connected to other living
things around us
what makes us who we are and how can we
explain some of the differences
as well as diseases that we experience
dna contains instructions for various
functions a cell must perform
to grow and maintain life therefore dna
contains both
actively needed recipes and all kinds of
other instructions that need to be
stored
but not necessarily used all the time
today
there are several competing human gene
databases with many thousands of
differences among them
and although the number of protein
coding genes has gradually converged
the number of other gene types has
exploded
the onyx technologies are used to
explore the roles relationships and
actions of the various types of
molecules
that make up the cell of an organisms
together these are referred to as
systems
biology many types of rmix data can be
generated
using various technologies one of them
is called
next generation sequencing or high
throughput sequencing
the data from high throughput sequencing
can be used to characterize
detailed genomic variants epigenomic
regulation
as well as gene and isoform expression
in this part we are going to be talking
about genomics
genomics refers to the structure
function
evolution and the sequence of dna
a specific type of variation can lead to
harmful results
for example a change in function that is
harmful
this is called a mutation most single
nucleotide changes are found
outside of the coding regions so these
are non-coding
variants and have no impact on the
biological function of a protein
or called silent though they may affect
gene expression or splicing
however variants found within the coding
region
may code for functional changes in amino
acid structure
called missense or predict premature
protein truncation
nonsense and thus may have a possible
direct association with disease
one example of a non-synonymous mutation
that is associated with a phenotype
change but not disease
is a mutation in the fgfs gene
that causes extremely long hair eyebrows
and eyelashes in people
depending on the type of sequencing
method fastq files can be quite large
sometimes over several gigabytes in size
per file
to analyze such raw data many different
tools for genomic data analysis are used
these include sequence alignment of
reads and full sequences
analysis of relationships between
sequences and their evolutionary
divergence
measurement of gene expression
relationships between sequences and
structures
as well as somatic and germline variant
calling methods
the t-bind info is an example of a big
data platform
developed for analysis and integration
of such data
it can be used to perform all of these
analyses and many others
using an intuitive and user-friendly
interface
one of the major objectives of genomics
is linked to sequence alignment
sequence alignment can refer to two
types of enlightenment
to learn more about these analysis
methods and their applications in
various project examples
you can complete the genomics course
series this series will include a more
expanded overview of key concepts
principles and examples of genomic data
analysis